EVERYONE WILL WATCH THIS WEEK
AHEAD.
MIKE: MARK MEREDITH, THINK
YOU’LL.
JOINING US FOR THIS AND OTHER
LITTLE DEVELOPMENTS LET’S BRING
IN OUR PANEL GOP PACK STRATEGIST
AND DEMOCRATIC STRATEGIST AND
FOX NEWS JESSICA, WELCOME BOTH
OF YOU.
WHAT DO YOU ANTICIPATE FOR THIS
WEEK’S CONFIRMATION JESSICA AND
THE NOMINATION BUDGET DIRECTOR
DEAD THAT WEST VIRGINIA SENATOR
SAYS HE’S A NO ON HER?
>> I WOULD NOT SAY INSTEAD BUT
IT WILL BE A LITTLE MORE
COMPLICATED THE DEMOCRATS HAD
HOPED AT THE BEGINNING.
I REMEMBER WE TALKED ABOUT THIS
WHEN JOE BIDEN PUT HER NAME IN
THE FIRST PLACE AND WE THOUGHT
POTENTIALLY SHE COULD’VE BEEN
THE SACRIFICIAL LAMB IN ALL OF
THIS BECAUSE WE KNEW REPUBLICANS
WOULD PRETEND THAT THEY CARED
ABOUT HER TWEETS AND DIDN’T CARE
ABOUT PRESIDENT TRUMP’S TWEETS
FOR FOUR OR FIVE YEARS.
I IMAGINE WE COULD PICK UP A
REPUBLICAN VOTER AND PRESIDENT
BIDEN HAS SAID HE STILL THINK
SHE’LL BE ABLE TO GET THROUGH.
MERRICK GARLAND I’M REALLY
EXCITED TO SEE BECAUSE RIGHT
AFTER MITCH MCCONNELL SAID HE
WAS NOT GOING TO VOTE TO CONVICT
PRESIDENT TRUMP IN THE
IMPEACHMENT HEARING, HE DID
ESSENTIALLY SIGNAL TO THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT, THIS IS FOR
YOU NOW, I DON’T THINK WE HAVE
THE POWER TO CONVICT HIM BUT YOU
DO, IT’LL BE INTERESTING TO SEE
HOW MANY REPUBLICANS ESPECIALLY
THOSE VOTED TO CONVICT PRESIDENT
TRUMP EXIT MERRICK GARLAND ON
ABOUT THAT AND TALK ABOUT HE
WILL TREAT THE FORMER PRESIDENT
AS WELL THOSE WHO PARTICIPATED
ON THE RIOTS ON JANUARY 6.
>> WHAT IS YOUR PRODUCTION FOR
THESE UPCOMING HEARINGS AND
CRITICAL CABINET SPOTS.
>> HOUTHIS COULD BE SETTING
PRESIDENT, HAS A MAJORITY SENATE
OF THE PRESIDENT NOT CONVERT HIS
NOMINEE.
PRESIDENT CLINTON, PRESIDENT
BUSH, THE SECOND AND PRESIDENT
OBAMA, ALL BECAUSE THE NOMINEES
HAD TAX ISSUES.
TANDON CAN BE THE FIRST ONE HE
DOESN’T GET CONFIRMED BECAUSE OF
HER VITRIOLIC MESSAGES THAT SHE
WOULD MAKE ON TWITTER AND OTHER
SOCIAL MEDIA PLATFORMS AS SHE
WENT AFTER U.S. SENATORS AND NOW
SHE’S BEING HELD ACCOUNTABLE.
EVEN MORE INTERESTING IS THE
FACT THAT WE HAVEN’T HAD A VOTE
ON THE SECRETARY OF EDUCATION
WHICH ARGUABLY IS ONE OF THE
MOST IMPORTANT POSITIONS RIGHT
NOW AS WE FACE TRYING TO GET
SCHOOLS OPEN AND I DON’T KNOW IF
IT’S BECAUSE CARDONA HAS
EXPRESSED AN INTEREST IN OPENING
SCHOOLS AND SCHUMER IS PUTTING
THEM ON THE BACK BURNER BUT YOU
WOULD’VE THOUGHT HE WOULD’VE
BEEN IN THE FIRST WEEK OF
CONFIRMATION.
IF THEY WERE TRULY TRYING TO GET
SCHOOLS OPEN.
MIKE: TO THE SCANDAL IN NEW YORK
STATE, ANDREW CUOMO THERE’S BEEN
USE OF THE IWORK, IMPEACHMENT,
IS HE IN SERIOUS TROUBLE?
>> I THINK IS IN SERIOUS TROUBLE
I’M NOT SURE IF HE’LL BE
IMPEACHED OVER THIS OR HOW FAR
IT WILL GO BUT THE FACT THAT WE
DO HAVE AN OPEN INVESTIGATION
AND HAS BEEN CONFIRMED IN NEW
YORK STATE AND SO MANY PEOPLE IN
HIS OWN PARTY WHO SERVED UNDER
HIM HAVE COME OUT AND SPOKEN OUT
AGAINST HIM GOING SO FAR SAYING
HE’S PERSONALLY THREATENED THEM
LIKE RON KIM THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER, IT’S NOT A GOOD COUPLE
OF WEEKS FOR THE NEW YORK
GOVERNOR AND I WISH THAT HE
WOULD HAVE MONTHS AGO BUT ALSO
EVEN TODAY WOULD GO A LONG WAY
TO COME OUT AND TALK ABOUT WHAT
HAPPENED AND OFFER AN APOLOGY.
WE ARE A FORGIVING COUNTRY AND
WE HAD NO IDEA WHAT COPAN WAS
GOING TO DO AND WORKING AND
PEOPLE MADE MISTAKES, GOVERNOR
PHIL MURPHY DID THE SAME THING
BUT HE DID NOT WIN AN EMMY FOR
IT OR WRITE A BOOK AT THE SAME
TIME AND I THINK GOVERNOR CUOMO
NEEDS TO FACE THE PUBLIC ON THIS
ONE.
MIKE: YOU HAVE TO SHOW SOME
HUMILITY.
DAVID?
>> THE COVER-UP IS ALWAYS WORSE
THAN THE CRIME OFTEN THAT IS
WHAT WERE SEEN HERE.
GOVERNOR CUOMO IS NOT GOING TO
GET EVEN IF HE IS PUSHED BY THE
DEMOCRATS HE WILL ULTIMATELY
STILL BE THERE NOMINEE WHICH
GIVES A BIG OPENING FOR
REPUBLICANS AS WE GO INTO THE
2022 ELECTION FOR US TO
POTENTIALLY PICK UP THE
GOVERNORSHIP OF NEW YORK.
MIKE: NEXT WEEK AND WE EXPECT
THE RETURN OF FORMER PRESIDENT
TRUMP BEFORE A FRIENDLY AUDIENCE
AT SEATAC.
JESSICA YOUR THOUGHTS?
>> IT’S GOING TO BE MUCH OF THE
SAME IN A BE INTERESTING TO SEE
HOW MUCH HE STAYS AWAY FROM
TALKING ABOUT THE BIG LIE THAT
HE ACTUALLY WON THE ELECTION
EVEN THOUGH WE KNOW HE LOST BUT
HE’S CLEARLY NOT TRYING TO TALK
ABOUT DOMINION OR SMART TAX
BECAUSE WE KNOW HE CAN BE SUED
WE NOTICE WHEN HE CALLED INTO
FOX NEWS AND ONE AMERICAN NEWS
THE DAY THAT RUSH LIMBAUGH
PASSED AWAY, I IMAGINE THE SAME
TALKING ABOUT HIS RECORD AND
DIGGING INTO THAT THAT HE IS
TRYING TO EXPLOIT BETWEEN HIS
SIDE OF THE PARTY AND THE
ESTABLISHMENT SIDE OF THE PARTY.
HE SAID HE WILL CAMPAIGN FOR
MAGA CANDIDATES WERE RUNNING
AGAINST US SITTING REPUBLICANS
WHICH WILL INFURIATE MITCH
MCCONNELL FURTHER.
MIKE: EQUIPPED FROM FORMER
ARKANSAS GOVERNOR MIKE HUCKABEE
AND I WILL GET YOU TO RESPOND.
>> THE FIRST THING THAT THE
PRESIDENT SHOULD SAY WHEN HE
GETS TO THE PODIUM AT CPAC, YOU
ALL MISS ME YET, WE MISS PRO
LIFE POLICY, WE MISS PRO AMERICA
POLICIES WE MISS THE PUSHBACK
AGAINST CHINA RATHER THAN
SURRENDERING TO THEM.
WE MISS THE INDEPENDENCE OF
HAVING AMERICA THAT HASN’T
SURRENDERED TO THE PARIS CLIMATE
RECORD AND ACTUALLY PUSHES FOR
REALIGNMENT OF THE MIDDLE EAST.
MIKE: DAVID YOUR THOUGHTS ON
THIS APPEARANCE?
>> AS MIKE HUCKABEE SAID
74 MILLION VOTED FOR PRESIDENT
TRUMP BECAUSE OF THE AGENDA THAT
HE PURSUED.
THE PRESIDENT GOING TO CPAC
UNDERSCORES THE IMPORTANCE
FLORIDA WILL PLAY IN 2024 FOR
THE REPUBLICAN NOMINATION.
ARGUABLY THERE ARE FOUR
REPUBLICANS LOOKING AT IT NOW,
GOVERNOR DESANTIS, SENATOR
SCOTT, SENATOR RUBIO AND FORMER
PRESIDENT TRUMP ALL LOOKING AT
MAKING A BID IN 2024.
IT IS HARD TO SEE 70 GETTING THE
NOMINATION AND NOT GOING THROUGH
FLORIDA AND IS UNDERSCORED BY